[Music]
what's up guys we're here to talk about
a brand new desk from avi desk local
company here in singapore if you guys
know you know me if you don't check them
out they make some really cool height
adjustable desks anyway they got a new
table top in the mix from the ichi
collection it's called the kawa the omni
desk likes japan of course can't travel
so we get a table top called that and
it's teak wood epoxy resin in the middle
you can obviously have your various
different options of that each piece is
original you'll never find two pieces
exactly the same
it's been in the house for a couple days
let's talk about it
[Music]
before we get into things big thanks to
omnidusk for sending this over for me to
test however we're not paid our sponsor
for this review my thoughts and my
thoughts only okay let's get into this
bad boy if you've never used a height
adjustable desk before once you do you
will be spoiled case in point i've been
actually using an omni desk for the past
year obviously a different table top it
goes up to 125 centimeters to the
highest level and then down to 60
centimeters it does have some sensors so
if you do have kids dogs or zacky gets
underneath your table it will let you
know
it will obviously adjust so it doesn't
hit anything so there is safety involved
with this you can also pre-program your
settings in there to various different
memory functions on that so you are good
to go one two three four it's not
because i don't know how to count so i
can set different height adjustments
inside the desk but
it always helps when i forget it comes
after three because i do need help with
my math sometimes i failed at math this
table top the kawa table top is unique
as i mentioned before in the opening of
this video each piece of wood is unique
to it you'll never find two exactly the
same you've got this epoxy resin here
which is blue there's multi layers that
go into this if you look at it very
closely it looks like a river
very peaceful ichi collection
table top i'm feeling like i'm in kyoto
right now i'm in my living room so
because i can't travel
none of us can
so i have a tabletop to remind me of
japan thanks omnidesk
[Music]
this is tekwood so this is a very very
beautiful wood
as you're going to notice on the curves
right here it has curvature to this
because this is very natural in its cut
and how it works now this does come in a
variety of different sizes
just like the other omni desk tables but
of course because it is natural wood
you're not going to always get 72 inches
60 inches or 48 or whatever size they
have it might vary by a couple different
inches case in point i had the 72 inch
desk previously this one is a little bit
shorter but i do not mind it because i
absolutely love the design and the
grains of this wood the way that it
comes in it looks like it's from one
piece of wood right here it just sort of
merges in the middle the patterns are
very very similar on each side and of
course it looks beautiful with this
epoxy resin now this epoxy resin is
interesting because it does give you a
little bit of a translucent feel to your
table but there is no ridge if you're
wondering if you're going to feel this
where the epoxy resin ends and the wood
meets you do not they've done a
phenomenal job in terms of sanding this
down to make it actually
perfect um has a nice little bit of a
coat to it but this is wood so
it will scratch
but even if it has some fine scratches
you're not going to see any sort of like
white marks into the wood it just
naturally goes into it but if you're
going to drink coffee or wine
as zacky always says hashtag use a
coaster because unless you want to add
character to your table which i don't
want to do
because this has to go back and
i don't think they want to see wine
you know chianti on their table because
that doesn't go with the japanese feel
is a nice red wine from italy
you never had candy the cool thing about
this table top which i actually prefer
over the other ones is this does not
feel like a work desk i mean of course
you can game on this you can do other
things but this also can be part of your
living room it can be through furniture
i'm putting the cameras that i review a
lot on this uh tabletop
just to kind of
show off the cameras a little bit
because they all go back sooner or later
and i cry but nonetheless it uh does add
a little bit of a nice element and of
course i've got my mandalorian helmet
here i've got my very cool batman and
wonder woman statue there sort of uh
you know go to my comic book days that i
enjoyed collecting batman i like batman
hence the batman chair
yeah
but that's pretty much it i mean in a
nutshell if you want to put a monitor
arm on this
you might find it a little bit
challenging because of the curvature of
the wood
so i would recommend if you want to put
a monitor use a stand for the monitor
here or you could use something like
this as well um just to sort of you know
keep it there but
cable management will be a little bit of
a challenge now omni desk underneath the
desk exactly will go underneath the desk
in just a second to show you what it
looks like there is a cable management
bar but it is not as good as what secret
lab is doing with the magnets
unfortunately so you will see some
cables that will come off the back end
of this but just make sure to tie them
up to look as neat as possible run them
into the cable management and you should
be good to go but again this is a it's
meant to show you the piece of wood it's
not the meant to drill a hole in the
middle of this like you would see on
other desks you don't want to do that
please don't ask your installer to do
that it will ruin the whole aesthetic of
his table because you never know one day
you might want to roll this around and
put it to a different side and then
you've got a big hole in your
table and that doesn't look good you'd
have to patch it up
you just don't want to do that also with
the omni desk you can actually put
wheels at the bottom of it so if you do
want to move it around your home or your
studio or your room wherever you're
going to put this desk you can do so and
this helps out a lot because the desk is
quite heavy especially with this kawa
tabletop on it so wheels are definitely
in my personal opinion a must-have those
are my thoughts on the table to be
honest with you it's pretty much
straightforward there's really not much
to say in this in that regard
you can choose the various different
woods you can actually go down to the
showroom if you're in singapore to
select your tabletop and if you're not a
fan of the blue they actually have a
pure wooden table top it is much thicker
than this and it's much heavier
but i'm also hearing that omni desk
might come out with other colors in the
very near future so do take a look out
on their website for that if and when
it comes out don't have any confirmation
on it yet but i'm hearing this could be
a possibility so you could actually add
some unique colors to this as well but i
love it i think it's beautiful it's in
my living room right now and
this is a piece of furniture so i can
actually just kind of bring this down a
little bit
and i can uh
you know
put things there and yeah it looks great
this can be part of my living room now i
can sit on it too it can hold my weight
but i don't want to do that
should i do attacking
oh this is exciting
wow oh i wasn't expecting that i can
have fun with my omni desk in a
different way
ah
it works
it works it works yay
that is the omnidesk kawa tabletop ichi
collection uh the price point on these
are
quite expensive to be honest with you so
these are an investment piece depending
on the piece that you can get can run up
to a couple thousand dollars and more
you know if you're looking for something
unique in your home or in your office or
your studio or if you want a great table
for your living room or dining room do
take a look at this i think you might
enjoy it because it does give you that
functionality to be a workstation
you can tight adjustable
you have all your cable management
underneath it
i think it
fits a lot of people's needs out there
anyway guys those are my thoughts on the
ami desk kawa tabletop from the ichi
collection absolutely love it it's
beautiful um i definitely would
recommend investing in something like
this if you need something for your home
your office your studio you want
something different from the standard
desktop this is a beautiful piece and
one that you're going to keep for years
so with that yeah i mean
i'm a fan but anyway let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
would this be a table top that you would
invest in would you rather just get a
standard one or
are you debating between getting this or
the secret lab magnus desk that we
reviewed well actually we might do a
comparison between these two
and uh we'll let you know our thoughts
on that video coming up very very soon
anyway guys take care stay safe and i'll
chat you the next one and don't forget
to subscribe and like this video helps
out the channel quite a bit take care
guys
this table is art
it's not just a table
it's a piece of life
the wood had life
epoxy resin not really but the wood and
life
[Applause]
[Music]
you